I'm a guinea pig use your time I'm a
guinea pig okay okay
hi I'm destiny and today I'm gonna let a
six-year-old play on my entire date
hi my name is usman today I'm gonna give
destiny dating advice
you know I originally volunteered for
this because I like kids and it sounded
like a really really really fun idea in
retrospect I'm now having some doubts so
I'm a little nervous in the girl roses
and some high conflicts a date that I'm
going on is our first date first
impressions are everything and I'm a bit
nervous that he's gonna think oh that's
tough but you chose her that's what
we're doing or that's what we're talking
about are you okay
kids are just so imaginative and really
think of like the first thing that comes
to their mind where as adults we kind of
like premeditating we plan kids are like
what's your favorite snack that's also
useful information so I'm kind of
excited about the conversation we might
have ok yes Mara so I brought some
clothes for you to look at some shoes
some hats and some jewelry want to take
a peek through and see what we're
working with
okay oh you already know you went
straight for it Oh Oh boots this was
good for a date a dress okay I like this
dress it's a good date dress because if
you're gonna day in a dress you're gonna
date you need a dress so let's really
see okay I think hmm those are fine I
love myself it wouldn't have to have you
come over and dress me more often super
cute yeah and these how does this look
good okay so we have the dress and the
earrings and the shoes you want to pick
a jacket for me I brought these three
bow this one good old rusty trusty
leather because I kind of like the car
lock so do i and my hair looks kind of
blackish but it's actually broom so I
like me here say I'm not here to yeah
I'm actually really excited about this
outfit this is something I feel like I
kind of would wear so like I think it's
cute and I think my date will be
pleasantly surprised
so as Mara what do you think that me and
my date should do on our date we should
go on this Lake Restaurant restaurant I
love that what kind of food like what's
your favorite type of food chicken and
fries chicken and fries YUM so you guys
can pick the outside but I'll tell
everybody to stay inside so everybody
stays inside we sit outside yeah so you
were great at this they're nice to me in
the night because that's more romantic
oh so it has to be at nighttime so what
drink should we have with our chicken
and fries soda a nice like soda a nice
look together what kind of soda plain
soda plain soda
yeah healthy okay do we have any
appetizers sure what kind of attire
should be great I didn't even like to
try a listers balusters fancy after
dinner should we do dessert what kind of
dessert a chocolate bouquet a chocolate
bouquet where have you seen that I saw
in this like fancy restaurant what does
the chocolate the code oh it's like
melted chocolate with the fountain not
such an icon yet so like like just like
running and cascading down and that's
okay yeah just like that I love that
what should me and my date talk about
when we're having our chicken and fries
you have a puppy or Kitty cat I do have
a puppy a puppy
okay we could do that and like when
they're gonna grow up okay I have a
guinea pig you should talk to my guinea
pig guinea pigs the only bits are
awesome he might have a guinea pig he
wants to talk about what else should we
talk about I don't really remember okay
doc I'm not a remember girl I'm not a
remember girl either
am i with you at five by five for not
remembering anything
so the night has come I am all dressed
and POSCO be my date I gave him the memo
about flowers in chocolate
so hopefully he he did some nervous
their first date
hopefully there's a good one
[Music]
or so I do need to say your nails to
match me right oh my goodness you are so
considerate I love that thank you thank
you okay you ready for dinner yes let's
do it you
[Music]
all right Jeffrey so for the meal
tonight we're gonna get some oysters as
an appetizer how do you feel about that
is that cool sweet great sirs I've never
had them but um it'll be interesting
okay first time for everything and then
also for dinner we're gonna have some
chicken and fries is that cool
okay go back for dessert we're doing
those little fans how's the chicken
fingers and fries not really as fancy
but hey I'm down and then how do you
feel about soda water is not my forte I
like just soda okay so I know we were
supposed to come to the spot when it was
dark outside but this is like as dark as
it gets
it's like almost six o'clock in the
summertime so it doesn't really get that
dark so sorry we're sitting outdoors yes
yeah listening outdoors all of you I
think I might have allergies okay I had
allergies a shrimp before I don't wanna
risk it I want to just enjoy our day so
I'm gonna I'm gonna pass on this one
we'll listen if talking will so people
in the comments no we're not going to
alright we saw our plain soda Cheers
they did not have chicken and fries the
closest we could get was a chicken
sandwich with fries what do you think
good choice clean it works out chicken
sandwich chicken finger is it ripping
ticket is chicken - chicken sandwich go
so good how do you feel
Jeanne pollutes I'm indeed one they kind
of freaks me out
because I never really liked it more
like a dog first day what'd you think of
the hood oh yeah I'm but I need to save
some room for dessert
okay we got Tiger cake right we do find
a chocolate bouquet what I call it a
bouquet with it cake okay okay either
way I'm down I like chocolate so just
get it
alrighty our chocolate bouquet like
weirded out by the food choices I made
or the conversation began right word
right word this was a six-year-olds idea
so it really was a kid yeah it was cool
I enjoyed it I thought you just wanted
to take a brother you know Wine and Dine
me what she wanted Wow so I just
finished my date with Geoffrey honestly
like it was so great he's so sweet he's
really fun he was definitely a trooper
through the seafood but all about we had
a really good time I think I would
definitely let a six-year-old
specifically Asmara
pick our dates way more often because
this is really fun so yeah I have fun
this is a great time
[Music]
[Music]